[Music]  Charlie I was a massive deal what you  doing what are you doing here where is  my cash money for the electricity team  I've got you tonight okay it's a  Nigerian world-class BJ it's gonna be  the song of the summer yes  a nanny nanny Messara yeah yeah guys it  was wicked seeing you I see you expects  my burning mug I'm sick of having  strangers punch my kid do you know how  long an average it takes me to make a  nanny clay  well I'm eight kids ain't my thing you  feeling abandoned - we're gonna  collaborate I want the truth  my parents think that I'm a fake music  local where you say stacking your  [Music]  [ __ ] stupid what you are  [Music]  the piece of the lemonade what's this  that fufu that's what I call my vagina  [Music]